you're a judge on on legendary you you
say that you can't dance and you posted
a video to prove you can't dance I think
we have a clip of that right now
I think everyone can dance it's just the
willingness to put yourself out there
so I approve of your dancing you know
and you you also have been on record as
saying clearly you have many talents but
you think you have odd talents you think
you have strange talents for example you
say that you can stretch your face I
don't even know what you're talking
about
oh my god oh my god it's in your face or
like your whole-- by god oh my god I can
also kiss my own ass I'm not gonna do
that right now you can kiss your own ass
no one else to do it which way do you go
do you go back I have forward you go
forward and yeah go for word easier just
a little I learned that when I was 9
years old it was not a sexual thing I'm
not like my dog barreled no no
just like I I belong in a circus not
school I would go to that circus
I'd be the creep that was at the circus
every single I find a dislocated soldier
to be very erotic
I just do so that's Mike you actually
nailed my kink one of 75,000 kinks
everyone put your erections away okay as
I told you this is a show primarily for
children and hosted by a child
a man-child sadly